WESTON HUTCHINS: Welcome to
"Cloud OnAir," live webinars
from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Weston Hutchins.
I'm a product manager on GKE.
INES ENVID: And my
name is Ines Envid.
I'm a product manager in GKE as
well, focusing on networking.
WESTON HUTCHINS:
And today, we're
talking about three
reasons why you
should run your enterprise
workloads on Google Kubernetes
Engine.
So you can ask questions at
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
With that, let's get started.
So it's no secret that
containers are generating
more and more buzz every day.
And it's pretty much a
requirement for enterprises
today to have containers as
part of their long-term IT
roadmap and strategy.
[? Gardner ?]
estimates that by 2020,
50% of global organizations
will be running
containerized
workloads in production
across a wide variety of
industries, including finance,
media, manufacturing, and more.
So as part of any strong
container management platform,
you need to make
sure that Kubernetes
is in the conversation for
orchestrating those workloads
as you start to move
from virtual machines
over to a container-based
infrastructure.
Now, for those that aren't
familiar with Kubernetes,
this isn't going to be a deep
dive or anything like that.
But I did want to at least
talk a little bit about some
of the benefits that Kubernetes
gives you out of the box.
Kubernetes is an open, portable,
container-centric management
platform.
And a lot of what
Kubernetes does
is build a platform to
help you extend and manage
your applications
that are containerized
on the underlying
infrastructure that you have.
For me, Kubernetes is really
two main key components.
The first one is that it's
an infrastructure abstraction
layer.
When you go and create
a Kubernetes cluster,
Kubernetes hides a lot of the
underlying infrastructure,
things like networking,
storage, compute.
You don't really have to think
about the nuances of that
from platform to platform.
Kubernetes gives you a
standardized infrastructure
layer to program your
applications against.
The second piece
is that it's a set
of declarative APIs for managing
application-centric workloads.
So as you start to
roll out applications,
there are a number
of things that you
need to handle, including
things like making
your application available,
health checking, making sure
that you're load balancing
between different services
in your cluster.
And one of the nice
things about Kubernetes
is that it has
built-in primitives
to handle a lot of those
application management
features for you automatically.
Kubernetes can be a little
complex, especially when
you're getting started.
But if you think
about what it normally
takes to run a production
grade application,
there is a ton of things
that Kubernetes gives you out
of the box just to make
your life a lot simpler.
So just to cherry pick a few of
these, looking at scheduling.
So across the fleet of
instances that I have set up
around the world,
how do I decide
where to take
containers and pods
and schedule those across
the different nodes?
How do I ensure that my
applications are always
up-to-date and
healthy, even though I
know that failures can occur?
Kubernetes allows you to
go and restart those pods
and restart those
applications when
things don't go quite right.
We handle things like load
balancing and scaling.
Kubernetes has
built-in primitives
for making sure that
your cluster is always
able to handle the load
that hits it on peak hours,
and then scale back down
during off-peak hours
to save you money when you're
running your cluster at scale.
It has built-in primitives
for storage, volumes
that work across a number of
different cloud providers,
and gives you a nice, portable
abstraction layer to say,
I want disk storage
and have that work
well across GCP and AWS and
even on on-prem systems.
And then it includes a lot of
built-in tools and services
on top of everything that
Kubernetes gives you out
of the box, so things like
logging and monitoring.
There's a ton of extensions
and pluggable frameworks
for making your
cluster observable
and making your apps observable
within those clusters.
So while Kubernetes can
feel a bit daunting,
I think as people
start to get ramped up
with the platform
around Kubernetes,
you'll see that a lot of these
features that Kubernetes gives
you means that you don't have
to think about these yourself
when you're rolling
out your containers.
So what we've actually
seen is an increase
in usage in Kubernetes
quite substantially.
The rapid adoption
has been dramatic.
I went to KubeCon
here in Seattle
just a couple of
years ago and there's
been a 10x increase from the
latest KubeCon that just was
hosted in Copenhagen. And recent
surveys suggest that over 54%
of Fortune 100 companies
are using Kubernetes
in production today.
So there's really no
better time to get started
experimenting with
the containers
and using Kubernetes
as your orchestration
platform of choice.
But by far, the easiest way
to get started with Kubernetes
is to use Google's fully
managed Kubernetes solution,
Kubernetes Engine.
Some of the biggest benefits
to using Kubernetes Engine
is that you can start your
cluster with a single click.
And once you have that
cluster provisioned,
you can view all of the
workloads in the Google Cloud
console from this
beautiful UI screen.
So you can see things
like what applications
are running across my cluster,
what services are there,
how do I set up service
discovery and load
balancing across the different
services within the cluster,
and even start to tweak things
like configuration of secrets
and config maps that
are in your clusters
all from the Google
Cloud Platform console.
But by far the
best part about GKE
and the one that we hear
repeatedly from customers
is that Google manages the
cluster for you so you don't
have to manage it yourself.
There are a lot of
day two operations
that are just
challenging, things
like making sure
that etcd is scaled,
making sure that
etcd is backed up,
having high
availability components
as part of your control plan
that can resist outages.
There's a lot of
domain knowledge
that comes in managing
a Kubernetes cluster
and Google Kubernetes
Engine handles a lot
of that hard work for you.
So in this webinar,
we're going to primarily
be focusing on a few of the
attributes and considerations
that you need to think
about when you're starting
to move from a VM world over to
something built on containers
and Kubernetes.
There are a lot of
fundamental questions
that you need to start
thinking through, such as,
how does Kubernetes fit
into the operational model
that I already have?
I have people that are used
to doing approval flows
and provisioning machines.
Can Kubernetes fit into
that system very well?
There's a bunch of
other things that you
need to start thinking
about, like scalability,
availability, security.
And for this webinar
in particular,
we're just going to be
focusing on three reasons
why you should start
thinking about Kubernetes
and especially start thinking
about using Google Kubernetes
Engine.
So the three key areas
we're going to be looking at
are reliability,
availability, and how
Kubernetes and GKE fits
into your company's
operational model.
So on reliability,
Google Kubernetes Engine
is already trusted by
many enterprises today.
And the reason is that
we've been doing containers
at scale for more than
a decade right now.
Internally, containers
have been used
as Borg, our internal
container orchestration
system all the way since 2006.
And then we started to
see containers really
pick up mind share in
the developer community.
So Docker was announced
in 2013 and started
to get a lot of traction.
And this is when
we started thinking
about how we could
help accelerate
the container-based application
environment by offering
primitives that helped
you run applications
built on containers.
And this is really where
we took the lessons
we've learned from our
internal system board
and started applying
it towards Kubernetes.
And around 2015 is when the
1.0 GA of Kubernetes launched.
And shortly after
that, we launched
the general availability of
our fully managed offering,
Kubernetes Engine.
And so the key message
here is that we've not only
been doing containers
for a long time,
we've been doing
Kubernetes for a long time.
So ever since
Kubernetes hit GA, we've
had a fully managed solution on
top of Google's Cloud Platform.
And we've learned a ton
by managing and operating
this over that period.
So there's a ton
of domain knowledge
that our SRE team has and our
dev has about what it takes
to run Kubernetes at scale.
Some of the nice features
that GKE gives you out
of the box, in terms
of reliability,
is just making sure
that your cluster is--
you can trust Google to
run your cluster for you.
So we do a lot of
things where we
take the control plane and the
complexities of running that,
and hand that over to
our SRE team and a lot
of the automation we've built
to run Kubernetes here on GCP.
So some of the
features we give you
are a managed
control plane, where
you can turn on features like
auto-repair and auto-upgrades,
which I'll talk
about in a minute.
We do a ton of testing
on Kubernetes versions
and node operating systems
to ensure compatibility.
And we have a long list
of configuration matrices
that we're always
testing to make sure
that we're rolling out new
versions of Kubernetes that
will not break your
existing cluster.
One of the really key features
of using something like GKE
is the deep integration that
we have with the [INAUDIBLE]
Google Cloud Platform.
So we have an amazing
[INAUDIBLE] system
that allows you to boot
our cluster faster than any
of the other cloud providers.
We have deep integration with
our networking and VPC stack,
which Ines will be
talking about shortly.
And then you can get features
like CI/CD, Container Builder
registry, logging and
monitoring tool in Stackdriver,
to just give you that
overall confidence
in operational ability
to consistently deploy
applications to your cluster and
then monitor those production
apps as they're out there
in your GKE cluster.
But by far, and I
mentioned this before,
the most important
thing is that we
have a set of SREs that are
always monitoring your cluster
and making changes.
Some of the actions
that they perform
are keeping etcd backed up and
recovered in case of a disaster
recovery, monitoring
for global outages
and making sure that we can
respond to those quickly,
and then alerting you
when there are problems
in the cluster that
you may be hitting,
like scalability
limits of Kubernetes,
such as too many name
spaces or too many services
that you've created.
And all this comes
out of the box
just by using GKE's platform.
So now, I want to talk
about availability.
And we recently launched
a number of new features
around availability.
These features are regional
clusters, node auto-repair,
and regional persistent disks,
which just went to beta.
The first feature that I want
to cover is regional clusters.
So we announced the
GA of this last week.
Regional clusters
is an improvement
on these zonal clusters that
we were offering for GKE.
And what it does is it
spreads your control plane
across three zones in a region.
And it also spreads your
nodes across three zones
in a region to give your app
increased availability as well.
All of this
communication happens
through a highly tolerant
load balancer system
so that even if one of
these were to go down,
you could always shift
traffic over to a new zone.
So the biggest benefits with
having this high availability
multi-master setup is
that you get an increased
SLO, an increased up
time as part of GKE,
where you get three
and a half [? nines. ?]
But by far, the feature that
we hear most of the customers
really wanted was this ability
to do zero downtime control
plane upgrades.
So as we start rolling out
new versions of Kubernetes,
we will actually do a one by
one upgrade of your zonal--
or sorry-- of your
regional control plane
and upgrade each zone at a
time so that your control plane
is always having the
ability to serve traffic
for your applications.
As a quick aside, I do
want to talk a little bit
about upgrade strategies.
And these are just
general best practice tips
when you're thinking about,
how do I keep my app updated
and highly available
during an upgrade?
So I think one of the first
tips is using something
like regional clusters to make
sure you have zero downtime,
but let's cover a few other
general best practices here.
So just a brief primer
on the architecture,
the way Google Kubernetes
Engine is set up
is that you have a
control plane, which
is a set of master nodes
that are managed by Google.
And then you have
your nodes, which
are controlled by you
in your own project that
run your workloads.
And from the control
plane aspect,
Google manages the
upgrades for you.
So we will automatically
upgrade the control plane
as new versions of
Kubernetes are available.
Now, the thing to note
is that we don't always
upgrade every cluster to the
latest version of Kubernetes.
We typically pick a stable
version that's usually
one or two releases behind.
However, you as
the customer always
have the option of trying the
latest and greatest by clicking
the upgrade available link
inside the Google Cloud console
or running it from
a G Cloud command.
And the most important
piece about this
is you have control
over when you
want to upgrade to
the newest versions,
but we will always
make sure that security
patches and other
fixes are performed
on your cluster for
you automatically.
And as I mentioned
before, if you really
want to have increased
availability,
use zero downtime
during upgrade,
as it's a much better
model for maintaining
the up time of your cluster.
So past the control
plane, you need
to think about how you're going
to keep your nodes upgraded,
to make sure specifically that
they're available while you're
serving traffic.
So there's a couple features
that I wanted to mention.
First off, you can choose
to turn on auto-upgrade
for your cluster.
And this is particularly
what I recommend
for customers that want to
make sure that their cluster is
always kept up-to-date with
the latest security patches.
Or if you want more
control, you can
choose to turn off that
feature and manually upgrade
your cluster as newer
versions are supported.
One feature that you can use
to control when upgrades happen
is called maintenance windows.
And this feature allows you to
set a schedule and a four-hour
window of which you
say upgrades are
allowed to happen during
this particular time period.
And that just gives you
a little more confidence
that your cluster will always
be able to serve peak traffic,
but then we can keep things
upgraded when less load is
hitting the cluster.
But in terms of
upgrade strategy,
there's two common
patterns that I've seen
about keeping nodes up-to-date.
The first is just
what GKE gives you out
of the box, which
is a rolling update.
If you go and click
the button showing
in the bottom
right-hand corner here
around node upgrades
are available,
it'll walk you
through a wizard where
we will upgrade your cluster
one node at a time in a rolling
upgrade fashion.
This is nice just because
it's simple and easy,
but it does have one
big downside in that you
need to make sure
that your cluster can
operate with one reduced node
during that upgrade process.
So we will constantly be taking
a node down, draining it,
and then adding it back with
a newer version of Kubernetes.
One way to handle this
is just to provision
in an extra capacity during
your upgrade process.
And we hope to make this
more automatic and easier
in the future.
The second common
strategy that I see
is migration with node pools.
So one of the nice
things about node pools
is that it allows you to
create a group of nodes
on a newer version of Kubernetes
and do a form of traffic
shifting over to
that new version.
So what you can do is create
a second node pool as part
of the same cluster on a newer
version and then one by one,
use [? kubectl ?] to
go and drain the nodes,
and then [? cord ?]
on the nodes,
which will then start to
reschedule pods on the newer
version of Kubernetes.
And this allows you a
little bit more control
over the upgrade
process and also
gives you the ability to
roll back in case things
start going wrong.
So this is a really
nice process that you
can use in order to go
and upgrade your clusters
to the newest versions.
One other feature that
we just announced GA for
is auto-repair.
Now, your Kubernetes
cluster, your nodes
can go down for a
number of reasons.
There can be kernel bugs.
They can be unreachable.
You can have out of memory
or out of storage exceptions.
And what auto-repair
does is it constantly
is monitoring and health
checking your nodes.
And if it detects a problem
such as a node not responding,
it will go and
respin up those nodes
and keep that
cluster up-to-date.
What we found from
customers is this
is usually a feature
that they love
to just have on
in the background
and constantly
keeping those clusters
up as problems are introduced.
The other new feature
that we just announced
is regional persistent disk
support for Kubernetes Engine.
Now, one of the nice things
about regional persistent disks
is that typically, doing
distributed storage replication
is really challenging.
And what regional persistent
volumes give you the ability
to do is automatically replicate
between two zones in a region.
So rather than having
to think about how
do I shard my application
such that it's automatically
replicating across
different zones,
you can just replicate
at the storage layer
and have Google handle all of
that for you automatically.
So this is a huge time
saver and complexity reducer
for those that want
to have the increased
availability with having
storage replicated
across multiple
zones in a region.
And we've really seen
a lot of customers
come to depend and rely on the
high up time and availability
of GKE, especially around
events like Black Friday,
where we can see a massive
increase in traffic.
We have gone through
this many, many years
and are able to scale
up our clusters in order
to meet customer demand.
And with that, I will
hand it over to Ines.
INES ENVID: Thanks
so much, Weston.
I want this, well, then to
focus on the operational model
for your Kubernetes deployment.
And the reason why
I'll be focusing
on the networking, the
reason why this is important
is because enterprises run
their Kubernetes deployment
as part of the rest
of their deployments.
And we need to make
sure that everything
that we build, in terms of
the models fit into the VPC
and to a scale the
current deployments,
they also work for the
Kubernetes deployments.
So I'm going to be focusing
on a couple of very
important foundational
concepts that we have released
and that are going to allow
us to really provide you
with the tools and
the models that you'll
need for your deployment.
So I want to back
up a little bit
and talk about
Google VPC network.
There is a way this
is significant,
is because it really
provides very significant
advantages over some
other networking models.
So we have been
already work as Google,
we have significant expertise
on building global networks.
And we have done so for
our own business areas.
As we built our
public cloud model,
we really leveraged from
that global networking model,
exposing through the VPC the
possibility for you as a user
to build your global
piece of Google network
for your enterprises.
The reason why
that is significant
is because it
significantly reduced
the amount of operational
burden that you
will have on having
to [INAUDIBLE]
regional connectivity
domains and having that
offered to you by default.
It will as well mitigate
the fact that you need
to connect separately
from your data center, say,
if you have on-prem systems,
through separate connections,
like Google Cloud network will
offer you a single entry
point for all your deployments
globally.
And as well, it allows
you a centralized model
for having your security
and policy construct.
Now, when we're applying that
to Kubernetes, we are really
making sure that
everything that we
have built for any
type of deployments,
it works natively on Kubernetes.
So with that, I'm
going to introduce
the first key construct that you
will need for your Kubernetes
deployment.
It is what we call native
VPC Kubernetes Engine
clusters with Alias IP.
The reason why
this is significant
is because when we are working
with container deployments,
really the granularity at which
we are providing networking
functions is not any more the
granularity of a VM instance.
You need to provide
the networking
functions and the granularity
of IPs with represent spots.
And that, as a conjunction,
represents services
that get exposed to a user.
Now, when we are monitoring
the networking functions
for those spots and services,
things like IP allocation,
they are done through their
native VPC GKE clusters.
They're done natively as
part of our GCP model.
You can allocate, as part of
your VPC subnet, primary range
that it serves as the IP
allocation range from which
you are allocating IP for pods.
Then you can have
a secondary range
that you use for allocating
your service's IPs.
You can keep those
two separated.
But the nice thing is that by
doing the allocation as part
of your VPC model, you don't
need to have two separate IP
allocation systems,
one for your pods
and your service as part
of your GKE deployments,
another for your VMs as the
underlying infrastructure.
Additionally, the ability
to program directly these
pods as part of our
VPC infrastructure,
it makes sure that we
are addressing natively
those spots and those services,
program in our networking
stack.
That allows us to scale better.
It provides us with
advantages like security
because we're able to understand
which spots are allocated
in which VM instances.
And therefore, we're allowed to
implicitly apply anti-spoofing,
making sure that the
IPs from the pods
are really the
ones that are being
configured by you as a user.
And in general, it really
gives us the foundational block
to provide every single
networking service,
whether we're talking about
load balancing functions,
whether we're talking
about routing, exposing
those routes to the internet.
Everything, as part of the GKE
clusters, pods, and services,
are treated the same as we
will do with our VM instance
deployment.
Let's now talk about
the operational needs
for your Kubernetes Engine.
So we have seen the
following paradigm
when deploying Kubernetes
Engine clusters.
On one side, there is
usually network and security
administration that needs
to have some control,
if only to understand what are
the rules of connectivity, what
are firewalls, and what are the
security policies through which
the deployments
have been governed
as part of those deployments.
So there is a need for
having a centralized view
and a centralized admin for
certain very sensitive security
policies and routing policies.
On the other hand, you have the
paradigm in which dev op teams,
they need to be agile enough
so that they have the autonomy
to be able to deploy and to
operate their applications
without having to have
a very tight dependency
on the infrastructure and
those administrative policies.
So we see requirements,
so for those dev ops
to have separate billing,
separate quarters, separate IM
control so they can
be able to operate
their apps without stepping
into each other's feet.
The last is that when you're
deploying your GKE apps,
you want to make
sure that they are
able to communicate privately.
The reason why this
is important is
because when you're having a
microservice set of environment
and you're breaking
your [INAUDIBLE],,
it's very important that
those apps are still
able to communicate
without having
to be exposed to the internet.
And these requirements
are very important when
you have CI/CD
environments in which you
want to promote certain
apps from deployment
to test, to staging
and production.
So with that, I want
to back up a little bit
because the way these
problems have been resolved
has been suboptimal.
And that is where Google
Cloud is stepping up
to provide a solution that
really makes those requirements
with a solution that is suitable
for your operational needs.
So why those deployments
have been suboptimal?
So for example, one
very traditional way
of deploying GKE
clusters, it will
be to have it in your own
account, in your own project
so that you can have your
control for billing, for quota,
for identity and access
management policies restricted
to that cluster so that you have
the separations, its cluster
and each set of developers.
Then they're going
to be separated
by these type of controls.
And then they communicate
through VPC control.
But if you are really
deploying an application A
and application B as
part of the same cluster,
you are really
losing the control
on some of those policies.
So you get the communication
through the VPC network,
like in this
picture, but then you
are losing the ability
for those developers
to have their own quota,
to have their own billing.
The other option is now,
you separate them fully.
You have application A, which is
really restricted to a cluster,
to a single account.
Then you have
application B, which
is restricted to another
cluster, to another account.
But now, the VPCs that you
really connect those clusters
to, which provide
you your [INAUDIBLE]
connectivity domain,
are separated.
You're not really able
to communicate easily,
those applications.
And then you create silos.
So you are trading
off the communication
that you had in the previous
picture with the able
to control each of
the applications
that you gain in this picture.
In none of them you
have the optimal setup
for being able to separate
policies and control
for those clusters, but
having private connectivity
without creating silos.
That is where the model for
the shared VPC comes in place.
And if you see at the
deployment that we
have here, what it allows you
is to really have your clusters
deployed separately
in different projects
that will have separate
billing accounts
for those applications, separate
quarter, separate identity
and administration, and
identity management.
Those policies are
still completely
separated for application
A and application B,
but there is still
a single VPC network
that is able to connect
both applications.
And not only is
it able to connect
privately both
applications, but it's also
able to provide a common
space in which there
can be a set of route, a set
of firewalls that are globally
administered by a security
networking admin that can then
gain control on how these
applications are communicating.
Now, it provides
you a single place
in which you can understand
what are the communication rules
and what are the
security policies
for those applications, without
having these dev ops having
to care about what
that connectivity
or what those rules are.
So to recap, when you are
deploying your applications
as part of your GKE deployment,
it is very important
that your developer should
be able to autonomously
develop and be able to
test and deploy and operate
their applications without
stepping on each other's toes.
Now, the developers are really
good at doing their job.
They're really good at having
their applications develop,
testing them, making
sure that they perform.
They should not be
responsible of having
to set up the networking,
the underlying networking
connectivity to
connect the others.
They should not have to
be responsible of how
do I now make my
connectivity available
to this other application that
I need to communicate with.
That is where the shared
VPC comes in place.
It gives us security
in networking.
I mean, not only
a place to control
that is very similar to the
traditional enterprise models,
but it gives you a way to enable
your developers for really
setting up for them
those communication
and those security
policy rules so
that it will make their
life really easy for them.
And just to recap, we have
seen tremendous traction
on adopting these
enterprise models.
We've got a lot of
feedback from lots
of enterprises in which the
shared VPC model is really
the choice for their large
enterprise deployments.
It's starting to be able to
achieve an operational model
that doesn't come up
with the trade-offs
that we have seen in the past.
And as well, we have
seen the customers
really acknowledging the
fact that we are providing
the networking
capabilities when it comes
to performance on a scale
to Kubernetes deployments
natively, the same
way that we are doing
for the rest of
the VM deployments
or any other type of
deployments on our platform.
So we really are going to
a model in which Kubernetes
and the container deployments
are first-class citizens
for everything on
networking, which
will allow our customers
to get advantage they want
from the performance, the global
scale, the global reachability
that Google network provides.
With that, I will wrap up here.
Stay tuned for
live Q&A because we
are going to be back
in less than a minute.
Thank you.
WESTON HUTCHINS: All
right, we're back.
And we'll take some questions
that we had during the session.
So the first
question is, what are
the differences between
multi-zone and regional
clusters?
So before we launched
regional clusters,
we had this concept called
multi-zone clusters.
And what it allowed you to
do is take a zonal control
plan that ran in a single zone
and then create node pools
in different zones.
So if you had a cluster that you
wanted to create in US Central
1A, you could then
add a node pool
that was in US Central
IB or 1C or wherever you
wanted to go and create those.
With regional clusters, we
give you that functionality
automatically out of the box.
So when you go and
create a cluster,
it automatically
spreads your nodes
across the different
zones for you.
The other major difference is
that we replicate the control
plane.
So we spread the masters
across three different zones
in a region and we replicate
etcd between those.
So multi-zone was
kind of the old way
of doing it for zonal clusters.
And it's still really good for
test clusters or development
clusters where you just want
to spin it up and add some more
capacity to try out
service discovery
across different zones.
Regional clusters
is really what you
want to be using for the
increased availability and zero
downtime that you
get for running
production-grade applications.
All right, so the
next question is, do I
have to spread my nodes across
three zones in a region?
And I think this is probably
specifically talking
about regional clusters.
I mentioned that we
automatically create node pools
in three zones in a
particular region,
but I do want to point out
that that's not a requirement.
So you can control both
where the nodes are created
and also how many nodes in each
of those zones are created.
So for example, by
passing in the flag,
there's a node
location flag that you
can use to actually create
a regional cluster that
is actually in a single zone.
So you might want
to do this in order
to save egress cross
between different zones
if you're not really sure about
how your cluster services are
communicating with one
another, or you just
want to keep everything
local to a zone,
but you want to have the
additional availability
of a regional control plane.
So it's really easy
to mix and match those
two just by specifying
the node locations flag.
And then if you want
to, you can even
specify the number
of nodes flag, which
allows you to say
whether or not you
want 1, 2, 3, n number
of nodes created
in each particular zone.
INES ENVID: All right, so
I'll take the next question.
When should I use shared
VPC for my GKE deployments?
So typically, you
want to use shared VPC
as long as you have
administrative separations
that you want to
provide autonomy.
And that could be
when you have, let's
say, a department A,
department B, that
are running different
applications, or even
to the granularity of a
specific application developer.
So you want to have application
A and application B separating
their own projects.
You can actually partition your
deployments to the granularity
that it suits you.
The shared VPC is going to
allow you to communicate really
those applications
that you are separating
for administrative reasons.
So we see different use cases,
from having two or three
big departments, or
maybe an environment
that is test, stage,
and production that
are separated and communicated
through a shared VPC.
Or we see to the granularity
of different developers
that are managing different
applications being separated
and connected
through a shared VPC.
So every time that you want to
provide network communication
that is private, that is
provided to your developers
as a service that they
have available to them--
that's where they
need to connect--
and you want to
keep them isolated,
in the sense of administratively
for having their own billing
quota and IM so
that they are owners
of their own resources,
that's where your shared VPC
models come in place.
I'll take the next
question as well.
If we expose
services inside VPC,
can they just stay
internal to the enterprise?
Absolutely.
So this is actually one of
the most prevalent models
in enterprise deployment.
There is the capability
to have your--
through the configuration of
the [? IS ?] IP that we just
talked about, you configure
your infrastructure VMs.
You configure your
pods and your services
as private IPs, configured as
part of the same VPC subnet.
And then you decide
which services
are going to be exposed.
Now, the fact that you're
exposing those services,
it totally doesn't need to
mean that you are exposing them
publicly.
You can expose them
within your VPC.
And because you now
have a shared VPC,
really you have a model in
which those services communicate
privately to your enterprise
across your different cluster
deployments.
And the last one, why are
native VPC clusters more secure?
One of the big things with
enabling with native VPC
clusters is the fact that
we, as a networking stack,
we understand where the pods
and where each of their services
are really located as part
of our infrastructure.
So what it means is that
we are able to understand
that applications are
hosted on a specific node,
on a specific host of
our infrastructure.
In doing so, we are then able
to apply security checks,
like IP spoofing.
And when we're actually allowing
traffic to a specific node,
we are allowing only traffic
for applications that having
configure as part of that node.
So if I have, let's say,
pod one with IP 10.0.0.1,
then I'm going to make a check
that the traffic [? destined ?]
to that node is
[? destined ?] to a pod IP
that it's hosting there.
And if not, I'm not going to
allow that traffic to come in.
So we really natively ensure
that the traffic is legit
when they're communicating
through our infrastructure
because we understand where
applications are hosting.
WESTON HUTCHINS: If you
have any other questions,
we'll be online afterwards
to help answer them.
You can use the platform,
type in your questions,
and we'll jump on with any
other thing that you have.
Now, stay tuned for the
next session, coming live
from Sunnyvale, "Why
APIs are products, not
one-off projects."
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]